this video is sponsored by radx and fund
domains which means we will have an ad
from them somewhere in the middle of the
video games journalists are bad at video
games which you know if you want the
really boring answer is partly true
partly not true it is what it is video
Dumb it's the most efficient YouTube
video anybody's ever made but this comes
up in conversation somewhat often and I
have some things to say in case you
missed it it's been in a couple of
conversations over the past few weeks uh
once again the games journalists are bad
at video games so first let me just give
you the context for the current
conversations and then we'll break down
the pieces and get to the spicy part
that everybody's going to hate me for
part one is that journalists got access
to Suicide Squad kill the Justice League
the latest game from Rock Steady that
for some reason is a multiplayer shooter
immediately received pretty negatively
my initial impressions of this game were
quite negative in a way that's like okay
you've got some interesting ideas here
but I this isn't what I want from Brock
steady kind of the same thing that
happened with Arcane and redfall I feel
like everybody you know myself included
watching those trailers was like I mean
maybe but why Rock Steady of course
known for making the Batman Arkham
series which is like one of my favorite
trilogies I also liked Origins so quad
quad quadr quadrilogy anyway very
excited to hear that rock said he was
working on something new and Suicide
Squad is not the same DNA whatsoever it
is an online live service game it's
microtransactions it is the games of
service that so much of the industry
wants because everybody's trying to
figure out out how to make as much money
as FIFA Ultimate Team genuinely FIFA
Ultimate Team has caused so many more of
these problems I'm sure I've said this
in a video recently it's like broke the
whole industry everybody's like okay
cool yeah I see that Batman Arkham
Asylum sold quite well but why didn't it
make FIFA Ultimate Team money because
edry releases a failure if it's not
making the most amount of money possible
like just a little bit of money isn't
okay it has to be the I digress so
Suicide Squad previews are relatively
negative one such preview is from Ian
Destin legary who I've mentioned on the
channel before and his preview is among
the chorus of other negative previews
for the game he says that there's a lot
of fun cut scenes and that cut scenes
have been given a lot of love character
models look great voice acting is on
point and that he genuinely laugh but
that it has messy and tied open world
missions which I think is again what I
expected I'll leave a link in the
description to where you can actually
read uh the full preview if you would
like to because the contents of the
preview itself are not really uh related
to this video except for the criticism
of The Flash boss fight the suggestion
being that uh Destin here or IGN did not
like playing Suicide Squad because they
are bad at this particular fight and
that it's ridiculous to suggest that the
flash is too fast is an issue uh here's
how it's actually framed in the preview
video there's no indication of where the
flash is most times and he's the Scarlet
Speedster so he's just constantly
zipping around the map that didn't make
the fight hard it just made it
frustrating you got a handful of shots
on him before he teleports to the next
location so you're just trying to chase
him down or catch him standing in one
spot long enough to get hits in before
he does it all again do I think it makes
sense that the flash is zipping around
the map yes literally what else would he
do do I think that that would be really
annoying to play also yes and this is
the second one right off to this I
thought it was just me but it also
happens in this provided footage
straight from WB well which is uh he
goes on to say he didn't feel like it
was clearly indicated when a certain
attack The Flash was going to hit you
even though you can kind of clearly see
this sort of straight from charge up
looking thing before it actually knocks
you back so that's the first of two
recent dramas the second one is related
to Dragon's Dogma it is time to talk
about fun domains fun domains is one of
the world's leading domain Registries
which is a more boring way of saying you
can now get a website with your name or
whatever else you want and do fun
afterwards instead of.com they have a
bunch of options but as a gamer fun is
obviously the coolest we're all about
fun we live for which is why I've
created my brand new website alana. fun
I'm planning to use it as a sort of Link
tree for now I'll put alana. fun and
maybe my social media bios and it'll
take people to a website where they can
find all of my social media in one handy
place which is so useful and you can set
up your new domain just as easily if you
don't want to create something new you
can also migrate an existing website to
your new Fon URL if you prefer to do
that and all I really had to do to set
mine up was go to www.g get. fun and
find the domain wanted ending with fun
which is all you have to do as well I
actually have a special coupon code for
you all to grab a fun domain for 90% off
with my code Alana that's www.g get. fun
where you can use my special coupon code
which is on screen now a a n ah to grab
a fund domain for 90% off it'll be
available in the description as well now
back to the video this one also focused
on IGN which I mean it happens because a
lot of people are going to watch an IGN
preview and a lot of people hate IGN so
this is a Reddit post that says IGN's
gameplay was really bad not the game the
gameplay IGN might have a big audience
but that's a bad thing when you let them
play your game genuinely one of the
worst ways to advertise it they can make
a phenomenal combat system look terrible
and boring I wouldn't blame people that
had never seen or heard of Dragon Dogma
to be put off by that gameplay it wasn't
a good representation at all when you
preview a game ensure it's played by
people who would do it justice I'm not
saying every preview has to be super
scripted pre-recorded setpiece having a
realistic representation of moment to
moment unscripted gameplay is fine but
you should at least have someone playing
that can show its full potential and
this attitude is actually a really big
part of what made me want to make this
video so if we get the boring parts of
this out of the way right Are there
games journalists who are bad at video
games absolutely yes like objectively of
course there are and I do think that
that's pretty insane considering it's
like your whole job is to be informed
about video games and inform an audience
about video games but that also applies
to literally every job there are people
who are bad at all jobs and yet they
still have those jobs I remember
watching a certain IGN employee who I
will not name play um The Legend of
Zelda breath of the wild they were like
[__] this game I hate this game right in
front of me because they kept getting
electrocuted while wearing metal and
like didn't make the connection that you
should not wear metal when there's
lightning and when I went to say
something they got really defensive and
didn't let me and I was like o like if
you are worse than the average gamer I
do feel like that's kind of an issue of
course there's the infamous cuphead
moment where a certain games journalist
couldn't get through the cuphead
tutorial which I don't even know how
that happened that that game is hard
that tutorial is not hard that's that is
such a wild story but then there are
just like boring realities of a it being
a job and B how gameplay works like
there are there are caveats right yes
there are people who are bad at video
games who still cover video games and I
do think that that could be like a huge
flaw in terms of serving the audience
and that's why usually people have like
a lane like there are games that you're
good at and games that you're not good
at but there are also like this is the
part of the video that's boring before I
get into my spicy tick there are also
just human realities like um I'm
actively aware that I not a games
journalist so the context is different
am bad at Allan Wake 2 because I'm
streaming it anxious by default while
playing a game like that and so I pay
way too much attention to what the chat
is saying to me and have as a result
dramatically overthought the game I was
told batteries are limited I just
stopped shooting the light at any of the
enemies because I was like panicked like
but they told me that I'll run out of
batteries and I and I but I never would
have felt that way if I weren't
streaming that game sometimes it's hard
to play a game when you're recording it
you're rushed you have people watching
you you have devs watching you it is not
like a normal environment in which you
play a video game again the boring part
humans but here's the part of this that
I wanted to say again based on this
exact Reddit post um and how many people
agreed with it and how many upvotes it
got um and I say this as somebody who is
extremely heavily biased in the
direction of Dragon Dogma 2 that is
currently my most anticipated game I
love the first dragon Dron Dogma I am an
enormous fan and I think that they're
well reasoned in the way that they wrote
this but there's just some parts of this
that I fundamentally disagree with that
I would just like like us to consider as
a community so when you preview your
game ensure it's played by people who
will do it justice you should at least
have someone playing that can show its
full potential these are sentences that
I pretty strongly disagree with and
think that we should all sort of be
against where game previews are
concerned in general to use a recent
example after Starfield came out I went
back and watched the Starfield direct
because that presentation got me so so
so hyped and my end feelings on
Starfield me and seemingly a lot of
other people is like kind of middling
there are things that I think are
exceptional I think the ship building is
like so much better than I even expected
I think it's so so so cool there are
things that I found to be really fun and
things that I found to be really
disappointing like very like up and down
in my opinions on the swath of things
that you can do in that game which is
like sort of in contrast with how I felt
about the original previews I thought
that the game looked absolutely
incredible so I wanted to sit down and
be like okay well how many things that
we saw in this gameplay preview in the
staffield direct were dishonest and the
one thing that I think bothered me the
most and and this is why this is
relevant to this video was they made the
combat in Starfield look so good because
it was so scripted that was not what the
average piece of combat in Starfield
looked like I felt like it looked like
such a huge leap up above previous games
and while it was an improvement from
previous Bethesda games it wasn't this
like new more traditional FPS style
combat that I think that I sort of
suspected based on the way it looked in
their gameplay previews they have played
through the level however many times
they have the right gun mods they know
exactly what to do to make it look as
cool as possible thus you get more
excited about it because you think
you're going to have that lived
experience every time you play it
Bethesda or Capcom in the case of Dragon
Dogma should not be curating people who
will make the game look as good as
possible or as this says have someone
playing that can show its full potential
I I disagree with that obviously we
don't want to see people who just suck
at video games playing something but
even then I feel like that's actually
kind of better than somebody who is
exceptional at it and thus will sell it
in the same way the marketing did if I'm
already watching a gameplay preview from
the dev team that's been curated by PR
and marketing is and is making the game
look the coolest version possible which
again is not necessarily the actual
player experience in my opinion it is
better to end up with a gameplay preview
where the person who's played it is
terrible at it so I see both versions it
is more helpful for me to see very
polish gameplay and terrible gameplay
and round them out and end up in the
middle and that's also a thing that that
Publishers do a lot which is make sure
journalists don't even get to capture
their own gameplay WB did that for that
flash fight probably because they knew
people would have trouble with it or
found it frustrating so when they
provide gameplay and so people are
giving you these previews and they're
talking about their experience of the
game but they're only able to use the
gameplay that was provided by the
publisher that's a very smart tactic for
the publisher to get to show you the
best looking version of the thing that
somebody's is trying to criticize they
don't get to show you the actual thing
they don't get to use footage of the
negative thing that they played through
while talking about it so you kind of
get like a a disconnect they might say
something negative but you see something
that looks positive so you write them
off just works in the Publisher's favor
really really well and I feel like we
have like some kind of at odds criticism
here right it very much feels like the
same group of people who yell oh games
Journal is [__] suck at video games
are the same people already in the back
of that same crowd yelling all games
journals are just in the [__] pockets
of Publishers and just doing whatever
the Publishers
say those two things are kind of at odds
with each other for games journalists to
help Publishers as much as possible they
would be absolutely experts at all video
games and make all video games in all of
their capture look Flawless that would
be the most beneficial option to the
publisher having somebody play something
that they're not good at is much more
beneficial to the audience again even
though it's frustrating than it is to
the publisher right better to be
authentic than to be marketing is
basically my point I do feel like a
games journalist who's going to an event
to capture a gameplay by default should
be probably average I don't think that
they should be exceptional there are
exceptions to that where there are games
that are hypers specific in terms of
skill fighting games it would be really
weird to have somebody go preview a
fighting game who's not a fighting game
expert that would be a really strange
choice I think racing Sims are similar I
would say first person and Shooters are
also pretty similar but for something
like a suicide squad or like a Dragon's
Dogma those are much more casual in
terms of genre and I would want the
person playing them to be much more
average in terms of skill rather than
either direction on that Skip and if
there's variation in that fine cool just
as long as what you're showing me is not
just like the same as the marketing and
so when we like shout that down I feel
like it's kind of counter to our own
interests sometimes does that make sense
I don't know you yell at me again it's
fine